hello everyone in my previous stream
there was a lot of talk about the French
defense I said about how I hated it you
know how I always lose against the
French defense and you asked me if I
could show a game where the French
defense was played really good and were
black wins and I told you I have just
the game and this is the game this is
the game from 1970 it was the Tournament
of Peace in it was played in Zagreb and
in rovinj in Croatia it was played
between Bobby Fischer and Vladimirovich
which are Croatian Grandmaster although
he was the Grandmaster at the time this
game was played I think he won his
international master title right after
this tournament but I'm not sure he
might - he might have wanted right
before the tournament but I think it was
after now allowed me to Karachi which
learned to play chess when he was 15
years old and already in the next year
he won sixth place in the junior
championship of Yugoslavia a year after
that he won the junior Croatian
championship and in that same year he
won third place in the junior
championship of Yugoslavia
so he's definitely a talented player
always was and he chose to be a chess
player after as his career some even
referred to him as the the amateur world
champion because later aside from being
a chess grandmaster he was also a chess
reporter for the radio in Croatia and
this is quite an interesting game
because Fischer won this tournament the
tournament of Peace in Rome in Zagreb
with two whole points ahead of everyone
else and in tight second were glia rich
last in the whole - Viktor Korchnoi I
can't remember who else was there
Tigran Petrosian was like sixth and
there were 18 other players with ten top
grandmasters from in the world and the
vitamin Camacho each one 10th place so
it was quite an amazing tournament and
this is the only game Fischer lost in
this tournament this was around 8
against Vladimir kolache which and prior
to this game Fischer didn't lose the
game for 3 years though his game fish
were lost before he lost this one was
against f'ing Geller and I think in 1967
in Skopje
so you know the Fisher didn't lose a lot
of games he before this game was like
5050 official games during his career so
okay that being said let's see this game
how does one play the French defense
efore by Fisher ecigs d4 d5 Knight to c3
and we have Bishop to b4 the vinegar
variation and the problem for Fischer in
this game is that Kawachi which played
the French defense his entire life and
although Fischer knew probably like 95%
of just theory
a lot of America watch which knew the
French defense better than Fischer so we
have 83 Bishop captures on c3b captures
on c3 and D captures on e4 Bishop sorry
Queen to g4 by Fischer now eyeing that
g7 pawn but this is a variation it's a
black often gives this pawn he plays
Knight to f6 attacking the Queen so
Fisher captures the pawn Queen captures
and g7r up to g8 and Queen to h6 and for
for the price of that one pawn black
will have a lot of development his
pieces are in the game this rock is
already owning the G file and it's a
it's considered to be an equal position
depends what you prefer
Knight B to d7 Knight to e2 and now here
comes a move that that Aladdin cahuachi
it says that he read in a Russian
magazine that he considers this to be a
great move in this position I think it's
by this is a move Russian Grand Master
vladimir alterative i think it's up or
it's our authoritative the move b6
developing the bishop to b7 like this
and after develop the Queen you Castle
queenside so Bishop to g5 by Fischer
Queen to e7 we have Queen to h4 now
adding more pressure to the h2 the f6
Knight Bishop to b7 preparing to castle
Fischer plays Knight to g3 and here
allarakha white rich plays
a most brilliant move the move is h6 and
this move gives a gives Fisher so much
trouble
the problem is you can't really grab
this pawn I mean you can but you'll see
what happens if you do if you play
Bishop captures on h6 you get rook to g4
and this pretty much traps your queen
well you don't lose the Queen the Queen
just can't move the Queen has to go to
h3 and after black castles even if you
attack drew you can't really attack the
rook with f3 or something you're gonna
completely destroy this pawn structure
that will protect your king in the end
because white doesn't really want to
Castle queenside that the Queen side is
busted open
but even if you attack the rook with a
move like Bishop to e2 after work to g6
that that Queen is still not leaving h3
so this would be very passive for
Fischer to play and after h6 if you
capture with the Queen this is actually
an extremely vibrant variation you get
Knight to g4 now attacking the Queen on
h6 and also this comes with a double
attack from the Queen and the rook to
the bishop on g5 so white has to grab
the Queen Bishop captures any 7-9
captures on h6 and this is the problem
now white loses the bishop the bishop
has nowhere to go
f6 is covered by the Knight g5 is
covered by the rook if you play Bishop
to h4 you get work to g4 and the bishop
is trapped if you don't go to h4 if you
go to for example before you get a 5 and
again the bishop is trapped so one crazy
variation where Fischer would lose a
piece as well after h6 Fischer is forced
to retreat with the bishop he plays
Bishop to d2 kawatche of each castles
and Bishop to e2 now Knights to f8
preparing Knight to g6 and here Fischer
castles this does seem like a good
opportunity now to grab the pawn on h6
but but if you capture it with Bishop
captures on h6 Rock to h8 and again
you're giving black too much activity
for this extra pawn as we have tonight
to have fate Fischer decided to castle
so here it is nice to g6 attacking the
Queen Queen captures on h6 now rook to
h8 Queen to g5 and rook D to g8 so okay
the g7 pawn was given as a variation and
the D H bone was also now given and now
Kawachi which has this beautiful rook
pair owning the G file in the H file and
this Bishop on b7 will become an
excellent piece once this pawn on e4
disappears and here a Fisher played a
move that he probably thought was
winning him the game Fischer played f3
it's very hard to find a move here for
white the best mode would probably be
something like c4 and then wait for
black to decide what to do at least
you're not allowing this night to jump
to d5 but Fischer played 8 f3 and he
thought this was completely fine for him
because if if black decides to play
something like Knight 2 H 4 it seems
like he's going for the Queen
but unfortunately white can simply
capture F captures on e4 give up the
Queen and after rook captures Bishop
captures now you're attacking that night
and f6 twice and it's very hard to find
a move for black here the best move but
by the engine is Knight to f5 but now we
simply capture the night and after
something like rook to g8 and Bishop to
f4 and Knight to e4 white does have
compensation for the Queen as he does
have a rook rook and the piece for the
Queen but the position does does seem
playable so this wouldn't this wouldn't
be a problem at all and if on f3 you
decided to play something like capture
on f3 you simply get Bishop captures on
f3 Knight to h4 now doesn't work
unfortunately because now the bishop can
capture would check King characters and
you simply lose a piece and if you don't
don't go for this knife to h4 idea then
the whites position is simply great
if white manages to
change this Bishop on v6 first bishop on
f3 then this is perfectly fine you can
play something like Bishop to a6 but
after Bishop to b2 you know a perfectly
fine position for white there's a still
a threat because the Queen and the rook
are attacking the knight on f6 no
problems professor here but Fischer
missed one move after f3 a lot America
watch which in this extremely critical
position plays a move I don't know very
few people would probably consider even
he played III and this move is so great
that there are even some stories going
around by some you know Fischer fans
that the Soviets were actually giving
moves to Vladimir cottage that they were
using Rona petrosyan demon Petros and
the wife to tell Kawachi which moves and
that that is the reason why he played
such a spectacular game against Bobby
Fischer but you know that's that's
complete nonsense he played this III
move and this is this is amazing what do
you do here is white well obviously your
Bishop is attacked on b2 if you play
something like Queen captures on e3 you
get 9th to d5 and this Queen really
doesn't have a lot of squares to go to
for example Queen g5 f 624 f5 now Queen
back to g5 Queen to h7 threatening h2
this is this is completely losing
position for white and after and after
e3 so
Fischer played Bishop captures on e3 now
nice to f8 was played opening up a
discovered attack from the rook to the
Queen Queen to b5 and now Knight to d5
and again that that Queen doesn't look
good on b5 the knight jumped to d5 and
now is attacking the bishop on e3
Fischer has to defend this and he
defends it which came to f2 would
unfortunately given up the h2 pawn a6
kicking the Queen away Queen to d3 and
we
Ruka captures an h2 rook to h1 now
official wants to exchange rooks but
Queen to h4 rook captures Queen captures
and night to f1 because there was a
threat of Queen captures on g3 and there
is no way to protect the night so the
knight has to move Knight to f1 was
played and now rook captures on g2 with
check King goes to e1 will Queen to h4
would check you can't block the check so
the King has to move came 2 d2 was
played and now Knight to g6 preparing to
jump to f4 Fischer tried rook to e1 but
now Knight to a4 with an attack on the
bishop and Queen Bishop captures Knight
captures and Queen to e3 here allowing
the kawatche which played rook to f2 and
in this position Bobby Fischer resigned
and lost the only game in this
tournament even though he wanted with
two points ahead of everyone else what's
the deal here well the material is
completely even here all the pieces are
the same on both sides and each player
has 5 points but there is not a single
piece Fischer can move you can't you
can't move the rook because rook has to
protect the bishop if the rook moves
rook captures Bishop you win the Queen
and the game
the Knight has nowhere to go the bishop
can't move because it's pinned and the
Queen can't move the knight is guarding
d3 and the only square you can move with
the queen is a 5 but if you play
something like 25 you get Bishop
captures on f3 adding one more attacker
of course the bishop can't capture
because it's Bend so there is really
nothing for Fischer to play here if you
try to move like sorry if you try to
move like King to c1 or something to get
away from the pin you simply get Knight
captures on e2 you lose a piece and
there is nothing you can do you can't
capture the net because then rook
captures on f1 winning the night and
there there is nothing nothing Fischer
could have done here dr. rook to f2 this
is the famous position
1970 Tournament of Peace in rovinj were
Croatian Grandmaster Vladimirovich which
defeated Bobby Fischer and even though
pretty much everyone in the world
considers this to be kawatche it's
immortal
Kawachi which himself does not think so
you know I'm sure he's very glad he
defeated Bobby Fischer and that he is
the only one and that managed to do it
but he actually considers his game
against Milan Mutulu which that was
played three years after this game well
not he's a mortal game he doesn't call
it his immortal game he says that that
is his best game so if you want if you
would like me to show that game as well
I will show it but it just heads up I
will call it then Kawachi which is
immortal game so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Mendel Jacobs for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon